[拍手]
[音楽]
皆さん
自分の周りに今あるものを聞かせていますか
もったいないっていう言葉が世界中で使われているようにいい
ものを大切にする意識が求められています
一方で
リフォーム
リユースリサイクル今あるものを生かす技術や2はどんどんシーカーしています
僕たちは意識を持つだけじゃなく技術はツールを駆使して
今あるものをうまく生かして生きていく必要があるんじゃないかなと思うんです
それでは皆さん
自分の中に今あるものを生かせていますか
僕は全く活かせていませんでした
それどころか自分の中には
何もないとさえ思っていました
高校時代僕は1学年450人ほど生徒のいる学校に通っていました
学校の成績は
入学してから
ずっと400番以下でした
一度も浮上することなく
卒業しました
大学受験はことごとく失敗
兵器の時は一行も受かりませんでした
浪人しても大して成績は変わりません
10校ほど受験してかろうじて拾ってくれたのは
1校だけでした
仲間と比べて
俺は頭が悪いなぁ
トーセ俺には才能無いんだって劣等感をたくさん集めてしまいました
その結果自分には何もない自信のない少年になってしまったんです
そんな僕が
その後弁護士になって今こうして皆さんの前に立たせてもらっています
当時の僕には想像できないことでした
ある出会いをきっかけに大きく変わることができたんです
僕が出会ったのは
ブレイクダンス
1970年代アメリカニューヨークで生まれたヒップホップカルチャーの
一つの要素です2018年には16歳から18歳までの若い世代のオリンピック
ユースオリンピックの正式種目になることも決まっていますすいませや世界中の人たち
に愛されるチャンスになりました
い
少しだけ
[音楽]
me
さてへ
このブレイクダンス
にはいろんな要素が求めます
ステップの技術 music power
オリジナリティ
先輩からはオリジナリティが大事だよって教わりました
お前らしさは何なんだって常に
常に問われ続けました
でも
先輩方は
オリジナリティの作り方について教えてくれませんでした
僕はどうやったら自分らしくなれるのか
自分らしさはどこにあるのか
さっぱりわかりませんでした
僕は劣等感を集め続けてました
自分には何もない今の自分を否定してたんです
だから
もっと勉強できるようにならなくちゃもっと頭良くならなくちゃって自分にない力を
求めました
自分には何もないか自分の外に答えを求めたんです
オリジナリティを追求した時も同じです
自分が本当にやりたいことではなく自分の外に答えを求めました
例えば流行に逆行してみたり
他の誰もやらない奇抜な動きを取り入れたり
自分が本当にやりたいことじゃなくて周りを見て周りの奴らと違う自分を作ろうとした
んです
でも
しっくり来ませんでした
本当に僕がやりたいことは何なんだろうって
自分自身がよくわからなくなってしまったんです
そんなとき
ある b ボーイと出会いました
彼の通りに試食衝撃を受けました
あ pv っていうのはブレイクダンスをするダンシーのことです
彼は世界トップ b 5位の一人です
彼の体にはある特徴がありました
足が不自由だということです
この酵母の病気で
足の成長が止まってしまったって聞いてます
世界トップ b 5位と聞いて一方で足が不自由て聞いて
頭の中にはてな浮かんだ方がいらっしゃるかもしれません
どうやってトップ美貌になったのっていっ
彼は
逆立ちを武器に踊ります
逆立ちで
軽く軽々とステップ
部分を取りをするんですそのパフォーマンスは圧巻です
足の成長が止まってしまったという彼の特徴確かに立ってを取るとネガティブな特徴か
もしれません
でも逆立ちをするとどうなるでしょうか
一般成人と比べて足の体重が軽いという点で逆立ちに生かし売るんですよ
ここで
僕の
大好きな
ev の映像をちょっとご覧いただきます
ん
xlg 映像はリスクの平均ま
ピッペンしてはいい
ん
ああああああああ
goo
ブーブー r
いいね web
bejean
ん
h 乳のっ
お召し上に会陰部
me
賢人
[音楽]
初めて町5
ですねっています
asme いって
he ん
ん
亜鉛スタップ
[音楽]
ん
me
[音楽]
ん
の
海は18歳で足を失いました
彼は規則も外してありのままの姿で踊っています
彼のシルエットや動きのフォームは決して僕には真似できません
規則を外したあとの踊りに美しさを感じるのは僕だけじゃないはずです
彼は失った力さえも
生かしているんです
彼らの踊りを見ると僕は胸が熱くなります
踊りがどうこうというよりも
ネガティブな特徴を背負いながら自分の中に可能性を見出してそして
努力と工夫を重ねる彼らの姿勢に
感動を覚えるんです
僕は
彼の姿勢から学びました
自分の中にない力を追い求めるんじゃなくて自分の中にある力を生かすことが大事だっ
ていう
そして
ポジティ部の特徴のみならずネガティブの特徴も含めて今自分が持っている力を生かす
ことが大事だという
僕は
当館を集め続けましただから僕の中にはネガティブな特徴ならいくらでもありました
そんなネガティブな特徴が
行かせるとする
僕の中にもあるかもしれないそうやって
お口の中の可能性を信じられるようになっていったんです
外に向いていた目線が
自分の中に
受けられるようになったんです
そんな僕は
ダンスに悪くれていましたけれどもある出来事をきっかけに
本気で弁護士を目指すことになってしまいました
でも司法試験をクリアするためには
大きな問題があったんです
小学校から大学を卒業するまで学校の成績が悪かった僕
勉強が苦手でした
大問題です
勉強が苦手な理由それは
暗記が苦手なことになりましたん
暗記が苦手だったら
勉強が多くなるはずないでしょう昔の僕だったらそうやって自分にない力を求めて
例えば暗記術を身につけようとしたかもしれません
でも僕は自分にない力を追い求めませんでした
知っていたんです自分の中に春を生かすことが大事だということ
ネガティブな特徴も行かせるって事を
僕は
暗記が苦手もあるかもしれない
そうやって暗記が苦手な理由を包囲されました
そして
暗記が苦手な理由は
お茶ごちゃ考えることにあるってことに気づいたんです
例えば何かを覚えるときに
そもそもなんでもない彼のから始まって
いやー言葉遣いなんでこんな難しいのとか
なんかさっきこの的出てきたよ何が違うのとかごちゃごちゃ考えるカラスのに入ってき
ません
でもこのごちゃごちゃ考えることも
行けネガティブに見えるけど僕にとってのはあるかもしれない
そう考えることができるようになっていました
ちょっと待ってよ
こちらこちら考えるの家
考えるっていうのは勉強に生かすんじゃないか
そこで僕は
勉強の次回から一切暗記を排除してい
すべて考えるだけの勉強に切り替えました
例えば
教授からこの条文大事だから抑えなさいって言われたら
や素直に思えません
そもそもなんでこの条文が定められているんだろうとか
裁判所はなんでこの言葉遣いをあえて選んだんだろうとか
この情報とこの条文の厳密な違い使い方の違いはどこにあるんだろうとか
こちらこちら考えるだけの勉強です
法律は言葉もむちゃくちゃ難しくて
めちゃくちゃとっつきにくい学問ですだからすぐに結果は出ませんでした
でも
こちらこちら考えることは
苦じゃなかったんです
ずっとやってきたことが立っ
時間かかりましたがだんだんと法律の仕組みがわかるようになっています
ごちゃごちゃ考え続けた結果浅い知識じゃなくて
深い議会が
についていったんです
5年かかりましたが
なんとか霧切市五色に高額することが
自分にない力を追い求めたんじゃなくて自分の中にある力を生かそうとしたことが勝因
だったと思っています
ある神経科学者が
数学の能力が向上すると脳の別の分野の活動が低下する
その逆もまた然りそんな研究結果を発表したそうです
つまり
ある能力が低いということはその裏側で脳の別の分野を活発に動かしている可能性が
あるということです
今節に従えば僕は
暗記が苦手の裏側で考える力を活発に動かしていたことになります
皆さんももし
才能無いなぁ能力無いなって感じたときはチャンスです
その内の裏側に隠れている
新しい才能に出会えるかもしれません
内の裏側には
あるんです
ちなみに
ちなみにですよ
司法試験
弁護士を志そうと思ってある出来事なんですけど
実際する
当時の感謝を振られたんです
あなたとの未来が見えませんっていうわけです
らしい
悔しいゆきみてろよって
シナた経験もあるんですね
弁護士になって
今でも僕は自分の中の春を生かすことをものすごく強く意識しています
僕にとってのあるは何だろうか
いろんな喜びを与えてくれたブレイクダンスは僕にとって大切なあるです
じゃあそのブレイクダンス便講師料で生かせるんか
10話です
確かに
委員会系では生かせるかもしれないよねって思ってくれる方いらっしゃると思う
いや確かに生きるんです結構受けるんです
でもそれだけじゃありません
ダンスは裁判でも行かせました
この写真はあるダンスにまつわる裁判で無罪を獲得した時の写真です
dj が音楽を鳴らしてお客さんが体を揺らす
クラブ僕もよく通っていました過去形ですよ
クラブは客にダンスをさせる営業だから許可なく営業しちゃダメだ
いわゆる風景法に違反したとしてあるクラブのオーナーさんが摘発されてしまった事件
の裁判です
僕は
僕のダンスの経験をぜひ活かしたいっ
思いましたそして
自分からも教えて弁護団に加えていただきました
裁判では僕はクラブの重要性とかクラブの価値を主張するパートを任されました
クラブは
表現者にとって
新しい表現にチャレンジできればそして表現した
その表現に対するリアクションをその場で直ちに生きることができる
バッ
つまり表現者にとっては表現の自由にとって重要な場所なんだ
そんな方的主張をすることができました
まさにダンスの経験が裁判できた瞬間でした
おかげで
うざいが獲得できたとは話しませんがちょっとは貢献できたと思っています
ちなみにこの格好良く作る写真なんですけど引きで見ると超内股なんですよ
すごい緊張したんですね
ちなみに僕がダンスを裁判で生かしたのは偶然じゃありません
皆さんカラーバス効果って聞いたことあります心理学の言葉なんですけど
例えばこの中で絶対にアカー見ちゃいけません
赤い蝋絶対に見ちゃいけません
アカーを見るの禁止ですって言ったら
あ母が目に付いちゃうんですよね
つまりある物事を意識するとその物事を探し出して
見つけることができるという理論です
僕はブレイクダンスをぜひ活かしたいそう思っていました
だから
ブレイクダンスを生かす場所を見つけることができたんです
皆さんもぜひ自分の中にある桜を強く意識してくださいそれを活かすことを強く意識し
てください
必ずそのあるを浸す場所が
見つかると思います
皆さんそれぞれのあるがー
あるを生かすことができれば皆さん一人一人が輝きます
そしてそんなみなさんが周りの仲間のあるを生かすことができれば
仲間のあるも輝き仲間が彼がいきます
そしてチームが輝きますさらに社会が輝きます
まさにゃシードですね
あるを生かす
大切なのは
皆さんの中にすでにあるということです
皆さんのあるわ
何ですか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]